folgt jetzt hier als nächste am
rednerpult alexander gauland der
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp resident
meine damen und herren wenn ein
außerirdischer sagen wir vor sechs
wochen auf deutschland geschickt hätte
und nun in den letzten tagen noch einmal
muss das gefühl haben ein meteor habe
eingeschlagen und einen putsch ausgelöst
dem nun auch die cdu-vorsitzende zum
opfer gefallen ist
doch meine damen und herren es gab weder
einen himmlischen steinschlag noch einen
putsch sondern es wurde in einem
deutschen parlament ein demokratischer
abgeordneter von anderen demokraten zum
ministerpräsidenten gewählt
das ist das ist die natürlichste und
demokratischste sache von der welt und
meine damen und herren es ist auch
natürlich und demokratisch dass eine
partei wenn sie sieht dass der eigene
kandidat keine chancen hat einen anderen
ihr immer noch mehr stehenden wählt
zumal wenn sie den wählern die abwahl
des alten ministerpräsidenten
versprochen hat soweit meine damen und
herren
nicht normal ist es in einer demokratie
das ergebnis rückgängig zu machen wie
die kanzlerin es formulierte weil die
abgegebenen stimmen ideologisch anrüchig
erscheinen
denn abgeordnete sind in ihrem
abstimmungsverhalten freiheit nicht
einmal walter ulbricht wäre hier frau
merkel gefolgt bei dem galt noch die
parole wir müssen alles in der hand
haben aber es muss demokratisch aussehen
und das sieht manchmal demokratisch aus
und nicht normal ist es meine damen und
herren wenn links straßenterror aus der
sogenannten zivilgesellschaft gegen
angehörige des gewählten und büros der
fdp diesen versuchten verfassungsbruch
nachdruck verschaffen soll
irgendeinen faschisten braucht die linke
offensichtlich immer meine damen und
herren wir wissen heute dass das
misstrauensvotum gegen willy brandt im
jahre 1972 an einer vom mfs gekauften
stimme gescheitert ist
niemand ist damals und später auf die
idee gekommen die erfolgreichen brand
jahre als illegitim zu betrachten
gemäß der neuen logik sind afd stimmen
offensichtlich schmutziger als gekaufte
msr stimmen
denn das gilt liebe bürgerliche kollegen
werden sie künftig häufig auf galle zu
koalitionen also alle gegen einen
zurückgreifen müssen was uns nur stärker
macht
ob sie das alles wirklich durchdacht
haben
der nächste schritt dürfte dann sein
dass das kooperationsverbot mit der
linken aufgerufen wird wie es herr
günther vorlaut und ich fürchte herr
günther setzt sich eher durch als herz
im jahr
denn so seine logik die hufeisen theorie
sei falsch man könnte die afg nicht mit
der linken vergleichen
stimmt stimmt an einem ende des
hufeisens steht eine demokratische
volkspartei am anderen ende stehen die
erben der mörder die noch immer
enteignung und sozialismus forderung
und sollte die cdu anders als herr
ziemlich jetzt sagt diesen weg gehen und
beispielsweise bodo ramelow ins amt
verhelfen
zitat wüssten nun wirklich niemand wer
wofür die cdu steht wie es der
kommentator der welt formuliert
meine damen und herren uns kann das nur
recht sein
wir wären dann die einzige
oppositionspartei und die union würde
die spd auf dem weg in die
bedeutungslosigkeit begleiten
[Applaus]
konrad adenauer und helmut kohl nicht
mehr erleben müssen
schade nur liebe kollegen von der cdu
dass dann eine bürgerliche mehrheit auf
lange zeit keine machtoption mehr sein
dürfte
dankeschön alexander gauland der
fraktionschef der fdp fraktion die